[Music]
ah
hello good afternoon my name is ismael
yuste and I'm a
google cloud deployment engineer in the professional
services area and I'm going to talk to you about
data modeling with bit query and data
studio for the next 45 minutes
we are going to talk about bit query
we will tell you some details about its
detailed architecture we will
also talk about some examples of
queries and how to unify
data sources from different sources and we will leave
some good practices to tell you
a little about how it works
finally we will talk a little bit about data
studio
well pic query  it is a tool it is
google's 100% being green data warehouse it
is focused on business data analysis
we do not have to
worry about the infrastructure that
is executing the queries or hosting
the data but we are only going to worry
about making that
data available to the  platform and execute those
queries in this case we will not
need an administ  system administrator or
a database administrator to
manage our entire infrastructure
big query scales up to petabytes of
data and allows us to perform queries in the
sql language that makes it
perfectly compatible with
traditional databases
these queries that we are going to be able to
execute allow us to return
results
in terabyte-sized data sets in
seconds and petabyte-sized data sets in
minutes, in
addition to this victory in crypting and
replicating your data to guarantee
security, availability and
durability of the same and it will also
allow us to manage access to
them with  claudia jump which is the
identity management system and access
to the google platform
in terms of costs we separate
storage and computing and that
allows us to scale and pay for use
based on the needs of each
of the areas we have a model  in
flat rate and we can also do let's say
cost per
use flat rate model  it would help us to
predict the costs if necessary and
all this at the speed of google
well big query has great virtues it
would allow us to analyze
huge data sets in real time it is a
service that does not need management as
we have mentioned the infrastructure it
manages  the service is guaranteed
by google and we are the ones who
manage it the service is in a
pay-per-use formula as we have mentioned the
storage is very cheap and has a
guarantee of durability and replication that is to
say the data will be there
forever and then it has  Some
audit logs so that the users who
access the data that make the
queries and the resources can be
managed and we can better analyze the
use of the platform. Finally, it
allows us to mix different data sets,
whether public or private, to obtain
results from them.
the scheme how bit query
works basically works based on projects
like the rest of the platform  rma we
would initially define a project on
the google cloud platform on that
we open our victory window and
how we are going to see later and we are going to
define a series of data sets that will allow us to
group the data according to
our needs and we will store
the data  in tables it is worth in addition to those
tables we are going to have queries seen
etcetera
big query passes its identity management
in the cloud have claudia mes the
identity and control system of the
google cloud platform this is going to allow us to
manage security at the
enterprise level we are going to  be able to grant access to
each resource in a granular way define
groups define access policies
who can avoid who can, for
example, carry out queries all in
a very simple and highly controlled manner
and with a fully detailed audit log
so that we will be able to
know who  has been executing a
certain query or who has been
creating a new dataset
in the case  or bit query we have
predefined levels of users who
would be the owner of the data
people who can write and people
who can read or execute queries
all this allows us to manage the level
of access to data at the table
level at the data set level  or at the project level,
all this depending on our
needs
very well and now we are going to show you a
first demo on big query with a
very interesting query this
first query is a table that has
about 700 gigabytes of information and that
we are going to consult
in a moment  It's going to return more than
10 billion records, okay, we're going
to query about those 10
billion records and in less than 10 seconds
we're going to get the result, all
with a cost of less than half a dollar in a
query of this type in a
depending on the
size of the hardware that is
executing this query or at least
late  It would take quite a few minutes or maybe hours
to return a result change
I am going to show you how we access bit
query basically the usual access is
a web
access we access through vic wearing dot
cloud dot google.com and you see that I am going to
access with my user to  the demo
we are going to load the first query
that we have here prepared in the form of a
view we are going to need
and we are going to load the query as you can see
the query is very simple
basically we are going to execute a
query on a wikipedia data set
that what we  I comment it has
700 gigabytes of information 10,000
million records we are going to execute it and we are going
to see how long it takes well you have seen
I told you before that it was 10 seconds in
this case as we had
executed the query during the break the
query is cached what does this
mean  we have that query that has already been
executed throughout today that
has remained for 24 hours in these 24
hours if this m is requested again  isma
query we are going to charge for it
because it is in memory it is stored
ok this has a great advantage when it
comes to, for example, disseminating data in
an organization that is
consulted repeatedly now what I am going to do
is basically remove the
let's say the parameter  to use the
cached data and we are going to
run it again I repeat 700 gigabyte 10,000
million records in less than 10
seconds it should return the result
it took 7 seconds
the demo worked well for me and we have that result
here the idea is that you see the power
that has bit query we have not had to
manage any server we are
working with an infrastructure
that is serving this
query engine and we are returning
results in a very short time
I challenge you to search within
our organizations for data sets of
this size and  that you try with your
usual query scheme to see
how long it takes
well and now what goes  What we are going to do is
tell you about the architecture that
makes this possible, okay,
Google Cloud, what it offers you is
basically a data center like your
own computer, what we are going to do
is use the architecture of this data
center to distribute the query to
a lot  of different machines and that
that query with that power that
you have just seen is executed in
parallel and returns those results in
such a short time
this is possible thanks, among other
things, to a
data network scheme called jupiter, basically it
is a  data network that allows us to
make transfers of petabytes per
second we are combining all of this with
servers that have latency of
microseconds and thus we achieve
unparalleled speed for this type of
operation this type of network is
used not only for big query but for
any of the applications
that google has running such
as youtube google search or google m  aps
and what I was telling you about this set
makes storage and computing power
immediately connected and can execute those
operations at the speed that google
needs
well bit query as a function a byc ware and
what it does is store the data in
form of columns this has been a
conclusion that has been reached
after seeing that most of the
queries that are executed on big data
have very few result columns
and that means that by having a
discrete number of fields we can store it
in columns  and taking advantage of that, let's say,
that column storage to
store each column in a certain
file, compress it and take advantage of that
efficiency that we have with the data,
well bit query then it is a
query tool and executes
processes in a massive and parallel way,
that is to say, this is not only  a handful
of virtual machines but it is a
collection of its services that will be
executing those queries d  I have done
Victor and it is a project that continues to
evolve. We offer this
query service, but the services
that are below it improve
over time.
For example, we change the
storage scheme, the computation scheme,
so that the results are
every day.  more efficient and faster
also because the data sets
grow when loading data as we see on
the left side of the screen we
basically have two options or load data
in the form of batch processes that we could
use for example data pro or in the form
of continuous data string that
we could use for example the case
of data flow in the previous talk
a little more detail has been told
but basically data prox would be our
implementation of hadoop and spark and the
case of data flow would be our
implementation of apache vibe
well data loading allows streams
of up to 100,000 rows per second and
loads of up to 15 strips in  batch ok
this should be enough for
most organizations even so it
can be paralyzed different projects can be generated
and work even
with, let's say, higher load ratios
this information that we load is going to be
stored in our
storage tools basically what I was telling you
before they are accessible to
computing services through a
beta bit network and that is going to allow us,
on the one hand, to access very quickly and, on the
other hand, to break down the queries into
small pieces that are going to be processed
in parallel that is worth what we get  It will
allow is to return results in
a very fast and very efficient way and all
this with the sql type language
with which we say that
practically anyone who has
worked with databases will be able to
work with this type of
tools
well what  is what we have under
this a technology called dremel
dremel is a paper that google released
a few years ago  because it basically
allows us to run scalable adoc queries
for
read-only data analysis okay and especially against
fields what we call flattened or
nested is how this performs better this
combines multilevel execution trees
with data organized in
columns okay and is capable  of executing
those aggregation queries on
tables with billions of records when he
talks about billions he talks about billions of
Europeans
all in seconds this system
scales over thousands of cpu and petabytes of
data okay and we use it
intensively in google
basically what we do is take  an
initial query we define the
data set on which the query is going to be
executed and we divide it into
smaller pieces so that each worker each
micro service is going to work with parts
from the initial data set
this system as you can see adapts to both
normalized systems as normalized schemas
as normalized
data
and is running  ar queries in levels
we will see it a bit in the following
slides it allows us to speed up the path to the
final result
ok another important concept within the
iris is the slots the slots are the
planning unit in beat query
ok they are basically logically
a unit of  parallel work that is
associated with a ram memory with a cpu
etcetera etcetera and what it measures is the
data processing it is going to measure
that capacity to process the data it is
a slot it is let's say an ephemeral worker
because basically it can be eliminated at
any time when  gives an error
we delete it and generate another one that is going to
give it take the job where the
previous one left off and then it can be deleted
when it is not used anymore this
basically allows us to execute or
grow the infrastructure to execute
the query and then when we finish
doing  the consultation we stop using
that infrastructure
the management of these slots basically what
we do is def  start 2000 per project
and those slots are distributed among the
simultaneous queries that we have in the
same project
they will be planned at the query level
for each of the query levels
we will see later and the use depends
on the complexity of the data  and the
volume of data that we are handling,
okay,
let's talk about the implementation of
the matrix algorithm in big query,
basically what we do is
store what I said were columnar files in a
storage environment, basically
hard disks, and each file is going to be
taken by a certain worker  to
start processing the data okay then
we have a series of workers that are going to
start working on that first part
of the map reviews which would be the mapping we
are going to map where the data is and how it
is organized from there that
first level of data  Once these
data have been mapped with the web clause, we then have
a tool called shuffle
that will order this tool, which
What it does is facilitate the following
processes. It is going to store in memory the
intermediate results produced in the
different processing steps
through a series of dedicated memory storage nodes.
Then, as you can see, the workers
shuffle that information and it is
going to return it.  then ordered in another
way so that in the last step of the
query, let's say triple is done,
that is, we are going to group and we are going to generate
the final result ok
the results are produced and
stored in memory and are used
by the workers in the following  level
as a source is worth peak query also
uses dynamic
data partitioning so that the execution of shuffle
is optimal if we have a file that
has a query that has too many
values or a file that
as a certain column that has too many values we are going to fi
d that  an
n extended resources error occurs within
the big query tool and we are going to
pe  dir a higher level of execution
okay, we're going to see what it is, let's say one
of the
sections of the bit query parts that is going to
ask for, let's say, more resources
basically we do an initial calculation
if the resources are exceeded we ask
you to go up the billing level to
to be able to execute that query because they
need more resources
and the query is very large also another
thing that we use in writing to
disk in general we store in memory
but if the query is going to be too
expensive what we do is write to disk
even if that query is a  a little slower
how would storage be managed in
victoria and well, as you can see we have
a series of columns that in the end
would be columnar files that are
stored on disk and what we are going to
do is replicate them in different areas
you see the case of the first column  which
is stored in zone b and in
two cases in zone c it is worth executing
a series of algorithms so that the
file is as available as possible  It is possible
that it will not be lost when
executing the different backup operations
etc. etc. It is worth then what we
guarantee is that storage
divided into three zones of the same
region that guarantees the
availability, scalability and
durability of the data
the data load  it is relatively
simple query is a tool you are
going to see very simple
to use it basically allows us to load data in
principle in three general formats that
are csv jason and I open the open format is
the one that is giving the best performance
especially when loading  data
with which
when you have one, let's say a
particularly large data source, it is
recommended to use that format as a
source and we will be able to
initially load it in three ways through
the command line with the quadri
tool pencil that we can execute either on
our local machine  or in the cloud with
the cloud shell the other option would be the
web interface that you have seen before  that
would allow us to load that data and
finally we can do it through
pitt query pie that would allow us to
integrate our application with victor and
directly this would be in general for
let's say the direct loading of the data if
we want we can use an
intermediate storage that would be
google cloud  storage that may
interest us at a given time to load
data, let's say from our data center
to cloud storage and then to bit query
depending on the bandwidth needs
of the time it takes to load
etc. etc. In
addition to that, once we have loaded
the  data what I tell you in any
of the three ways we can both create
let's say tables create data sets we can
add data to existing tables or
overwrite tables that already existed
ok
there is one last case that would be
updating data what
in general for the case of  vic wear and
is not recommended and in fact
update operations are limited
within it  to a database and they are also
more expensive than the
normal data load this is for a reason
basically let's say the approach
should be a datawarehouse designed
to consult data that is stored and
that has not changed it is worth it if what you
are looking for is  a database that
is horizontally scalable that has high
availability with a high number of
editions, which we recommend that you
use spanair, which is a very interesting alternative,
well, as we load the streaming data part,
here we have a diagram of
what the processes it executes would be like  bit
cuera internally when uploading
streaming data
in this case what is happening is
basically we have a data upload
that comes from whatever source and there are
some workers that are in charge of
doing that data ingestion it is worth in
time  they are actually throwing them into a
streaming buffer that basically what it
does is buffer the changes in rhythm
in that data load and it will  We can use this
information in two ways, let's say, the
first would be the one above that
allows us to make queries in real time, it's
okay as we are loading the data in
streaming, we already have the data
available to make a query and
on the other hand we are loading, let's say,
in a kind of process  batch the
information in the column storage
in fact you are going to see that when you load
data in streaming there may be a certain
delay between
let's say the data appears in
that column storage and it is
streaming but you can make queries
immediately thanks to the raiders that
are allowing  let's say that
read copy so that the body can
work with it
going back to the wikipedia example let's
see a little how it would execute the
query let's say in three steps
we had an initial step in which
we would do the grup vall with defining a
series of data sinks  basically
after that all that stored in
memory we would have the second step  which
would be the shuffle that would do the step of
grouping and ordering that information and
finally we would have the group and the
orderly let's say the grouped first and
finally a computer you can also see
that it defines the number of slots that
we would be using in each of the
steps this  it would be the query on
wikipedia not the one of 10 million but of
a billion but it would be more or less similar
as you can see this process is being
executed in a transparent way to the
user and it is part of the magic that
big query has behind it so that you can
execute your own
very well  and now we are going to see some
queries and we are going to see how big
query solves them and works on them
the first one would be the
new york taxis ok we are going to work with a
data set of information that has 170
million taxi trips in the
new york city is fine and what we are going to
do is make a
relatively simple query that what is going
to return us is what is the best month to
get a p  clothes like
a taxi driver in
new york city
the change is
okay then we have here the query
prepared
edit it one of the very
interesting things that big query has is on the
one hand the validator of results or
queries that we have in
let's say integrated in fact  If, for
example, I eliminate a certain
part of the expression here, it will
validate it again and it will give us an
error here saying that this query would not
execute
something else
and you see that it is giving us the suggestion that
there is an error in the sql no  We can
execute it
on the other hand, what
this validator is returning to us is
the volume of data that the query is going to return.
This is interesting when it comes
to knowing what the billing is going to be
and what we have about our bit query service that we are
going to execute.  the query this
should be a few seconds and
indeed in three seconds it has
processed those 170 million trips
it has returned us 5 gigabytes of information
or has p  processed and returns us in this
case 12 rows indicating that the
highest average tip would be that of the month
of December coincides with Christmas it
makes sense as
follows
the following query
is about US airports we are going to
work on two different data sets
in this case  it would be the
delay times of the airlines and a database of
the meteorological weather in the usa okay
let's consult
one
let's say the information of the
percentages of delay in the
laguardia airport when we had
rainy days all that
grouped by that of the line  So
we are going to consult, as you can see, two
data sources, the one that I have told you about the
airlines, the one that has been said about the
weather, we have the
station number of the airport of the guard
in that in that
meteorological database and we are going to tell it  let us
take out the days when the
precipitation is above zero
okay
and then you see here that we filter everything through the
airport  or makes a joint
with all this information and basically
we are going to get the number of delayed flights,
the total number and a
calculated percentage, ok,
we execute the query, it returns us in
this case 6 gb, we are taking 6
seconds
to execute the query, and we see here, well
which would be the airlines with the
highest percentage of delay you see that the
delays in this case this airline
has a delay of 70 percent
we could see the last airline in the
case of rain they have percentages of
delay between 50 and 70 percent
this information is  adding let's say
data sources from two different origins they
are different projects they are
different data sets in this case I do not
manage any of them they are public data
sets okay
finally we are
going to fight with one
with a slightly more
complicated query that would be one more function
let's say about data sources from
wikipedia ok sorry about jihad
we are going to make a query about the
same fu  data entity by making a
joint so that we are going to make
bit query suffer a little bit in this case we are
working on a data set of 700
gigabytes and 190 million records
okay and basically we are going to make a
joint between the authors and the people who
has made a commit against github projects,
it's the same thing, it informs us that the
query is correct, it returns 12
gb of data and we are going to execute it, this is going
to take a little longer, it should take
about 20 seconds,
let's see if luckily,
in this case they have  been nine
seconds instead of twenty to execute
basically what I am telling you in this case
we have made bit query suffer a little more
now we are going to see a graph of
how we say the query has been resolved
here we have a button called is a
little  the leather plan the explanation of
how the query has been executed as
you can see we have four levels in
which we have been working with 191
million records after that
we have had a q  One state in which it
has finished solving the join in
these two has been, as you can see,
spending
quite an important computing capacity and finally
it has returned those thousand records that
we have told it in the qualy and that the limit
of 1000 the return of records  in the
final result
instead
this query this would be the plan let's say
explained a screenshot of it
basically what you have just seen has
several interesting things it is
explaining us how much time let's say
percentage because it does it by a certain
approximation it has been waiting to
execute the query has  used in
reading operations used in
computation operations and
used in writing operations
okay as you can see there are two colors in the
specific case of compute in step 3 and
the darkest color would be let's say the
average and the lightest color would be  the
maximum is worth now we will talk a little about
what those values mean and how we ca
use them to  optimize the
big way queries
and also in each of the steps he
will explain to us what are the different,
let's say the different operations that he has
been doing within that step as
you can see in this case in step 5 he has done
a first operation of  read a
second read operation then it has
finished solving the joint applied the
limit and has done a memory write
to continue advancing in the query
well what are these query
plans for us so that we can take advantage of them
basically it will help us to
improve speed efficiency  and the cost that
we use in bit query, for example, if
we have a significant difference
between the mean and the maximum, it is likely
that we have biased data, okay,
then the general recommendation
would be to analyze them with some of the
tools that we have taught and
filter before in the  query order on the
other hand we spend most of the
time reading the data in the
state  s intermediate we again
recommend that there be filters okay we will be
able to work with less data and that
will make the query faster
and more efficient or in the case
of computing tasks as we have seen
in the previous query if we see that
it is taking a long time to calculate it
may be because we have the u
df functions the user functions are not fully
optimized we recommend using
approximate functions instead of
exact functions we have some
published paper out there that reports that the
error can be between 1 and  2% between
each other and as always filter
the query as soon as possible
phil we have less data we have and less
need for reading computing and others
we are going to have
another interesting topic the stuck
driver topic we recommend you use this
travel to monitor bit query okay
vickery has about 13 about 13 metrics
that we can use among them is the
use of the slots what are the strings
with  currents etc. etc. and all of
that will allow us to plan a bit
how we define the queries or how
we define the projects and the number of
slots etc. etc. okay stack
trader that I think we haven't talked about
too much during today's sessions
is a tool  that
google has integrated with the platform and that it can
be integrated with other clouds and that it
will allow us to monitor, analyze
blogs,
debug errors, visualize
code traces and manage error reports,
and all this with the possibility
of generating alerts both by sms and
by email so that at a given moment
those responsible for each project
can be aware of what
is happening
the price of beat query basically there are
three categories I was telling you we separate
between storage processing and
then we have some things that are
free worth
the case  of storage we charge for
the data stored for the data
uploaded in stream  ing and in the case
of old data what we do is move it
to a
longer-term storage and that is what we discount it is
worth second thing processing
we have both flat rate and pay per
use in the case of pay per use
let's say the cost is based  In the
processed data, that is why
the number of gigabytes returned by each
query is so important. The first number of queries is
free each month for all users,
not only in the free period with the
$300 voucher, it is forever,
the first number of data is  It's free
and then each tera has an
approximate cost of 5 dollars, that is, it is a
fairly cheap price and then to
carry out queries that need what
I was telling you at high levels of
computing, we need,
let's say, ask for the high computer is
finally free themes apart from the
tera  of monthly queries
batch data loading export
queries on metadata
cached queries you have already seen how  or it
worked which
we are going to charge for those that have errors and finally
we have not too long ago
10 gb of storage included in the
price voucher included in the service
with which you can start testing with a
fairly nice data set of about
10 gigabytes
and even a web of queries each month
will be free
more things we have a site where we have
all the vic query google documents
okay this I think it's in the cloud dot
google.com
harvick query barratt docs there you have
all the information you want for
start using the
query platform by
pencil detailed reference with tutorial concepts how
do I do this in such language etc
etc etc
besides that the public data sets the
same are also in
let's say the google cloud website and
we have a lot of data sets  public
either from wikipedia the airlines the
weather the taxis everything you have
seen that I have taught is in those
public data and  we also have
health data from new york cities chicago
public data from the usa whatever you want
is good so you can start playing with
it and practice
in terms of good practices we
share some that can be
useful the first would be about the
slots
when we execute  a query
basically wins and works with a
series of slots what we were talking about we have
2000 per project and that is batches the
computational capacity to execute the
bit query query the more slots the
more execution speed of a
certain query and the more
queries we have the more  we have
busy slots with which, let's say, we are going to
have a slower speed, it is worth the
recommendation as a good practice it is
for every 50 simultaneous queries to
define 2000 slots is worth 3 with a
project type we are going to be able to execute
up to 50 simultaneous queries of a
medium complexity let's say in the case  if you
want to execute more than 50
simultaneous queries we will be happy to
talk  ar with you to see your case
and of course what you do is ask for an
increase in slots in your account and that
's
another super interesting topic partition
by time natively big query
stores the data in a certain
table but we can define a partition
daily for the data this is super
interesting when we have data that is
going to be generated every day and is going to be
uploaded every day either in
streaming or in batch so what we
do is we define
specific partitions for each day and then when
we do  the queries we are going to define
let's say a timestamp to query a
certain table or
a range of dates in this way if
we have to query all the data of
a year of a certain
sales organization that is generating data
every day we can make the query on
the  complete data set or on the
complete table if we want to execute the
query on only a certain month
we will work with  the partitions of
those 30 days are worth
more topics of good practices the table
decor editors work similarly but
without data partition we have a table
or a series of data that are loaded in
streaming and that have a
loading time for that data we will be able to  do
exactly the same
query the data the last ones that
are available the last seven days
etc. etc. or with a certain
range of dates the same thing this makes
the queries faster
we work with less data and that they are
also cheaper
and finally the normalization  of the
data we are used to working
in a relational database with
different tables that are related
to each other the recommendation to upload
that information abi query is basically
either flatten the data or work with
nested or repeated formats such
as jason or abro  This is going to
make wear, and especially with very large tables,
have a
very good performance.  in and now we would need the last
step the icing on the cake which would be
google data study google data study
is a tool that is used to make
reports and panels or let's say
dashboards and that is focused on
business analysts it
is managed as if it were a
gis suite document you have already seen it before in
the previous presentation you define a
dashboard and data studio you share it with
your colleague so that he can edit it and
then you can share it in reading mode
with your entire department with your entire
division or with your entire company  ok it
does not require technical knowledge this is
very interesting it is business oriented
ok they are dashboards that are going to allow us to
take advantage of the strength of bit
query which are queries but
business oriented so that it can
generate beautiful reports and
cool results for the management  and it
connects with data sources
as we have seen bit query but
we can also connect with adwords
analytics  google spreadsheets or youtube
analytics
how to integrate this with bit query well
nothing basically we go to data studio
we create a new dashboard at the end it is
one more document that is stored in the
user's drive we create a new
data source that new source  of
data can be of all these types
we can upload a file adwords query
clau de sql whatever comes to mind is fine and
finally we authorize access to that
data the bit query panels the
reports will be linked let's say to
the permissions that the user has  user
of let's say the user who creates the
report or the permissions that the
end user has there we can decide
then we could perfectly make
available data that the rest of the
organization cannot access
natively through data studio or we can
limit access to the  data based
on different groups of permissions in the
organization we have that we can
define when creating the report
how it works  iona the collaboration you have
seen it the same in the previous talk for
those of you who have not been there basically
when a user edits a graph in
real time the other user is
refreshed ok that would be two
editing users in the case of having already published
the  dashboard when refreshing that panel
the new graph that
we have defined will appear ok
and now I will show you a data
studio dashboard so you can see a little how it
changes
the same thing we enter through data
studio google.com
change
and let's see
An example of data is fine, as you can see, they are
quite colorful reports that are very simple
to handle, okay, in this case it would be a
static example, we are going to see an example
that has information, the
possibility of filters,
and you see that in this case it would be a report
from a YouTube channel, we see that  it is
filtered for the last 28 days we are going to
tell it to filter the last
seven days we apply and execute the
query and update the data
very easy to use  ar and above all
free is worth that is
to data studio is free within
our organization to be able to
distribute the dashboards that
you want to use change
in conclusion we have talked about big query
which is a query tool for
big data that returns the result
of query  10,000 million
records in less than 10 seconds, all of
this for less than half a dollar is worth,
and there we can load our data in
batch or in stream and we can do
analysis in real time, then we have
seen data studio, which is a
free tool that allows us to collaborate in
our organization to create
those reports and dashboards
linked to bit query, being able to
share them in a very simple way
within our organization,
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]